I think a lot of comedians when they are
working on what they're doing a lot of
them don't want to be businessmen as
well they just want to go up and be
funny and they want to come to the club
they want the mic already to be there
and they just want to talk into it and
then they want to leave and they want to
get their check and they want to go and
when I was starting out I was in a
situation where there weren't theatres
in town that I could perform at and so I
would have to literally rent theatres
that I was at I remember I did a show
for two nights and and we spent $1,500
on the show and I had to do every aspect
of like buying all the props and
figuring out where the mics were gonna
go you know there were very few
comedians who wanted to do it because
the first obstacle that's right there is
like the equipment how do I record it
okay well you know most comedians don't
have a portable recording setup on their
own so right there it disqualifies
people and they're not interested in
buying it and then the other part of it
is is when you podcast it's like well
okay I recorded it how does it get on to
the Internet most people don't want to
take the time to figure that out so when
I first started podcasting I was I was
also a producer as well so I was used to
wrangling Talent and figuring out
equipment and and just kind of involved
in all aspects of it so when I first
started my podcast I would get really
interested in how it would get on to the
Internet and I didn't really know what
it was I didn't know that you had to put
it up on a hosting site then that
hosting site feeds it to the rest of the
world including iTunes and all that I
just thought like how do I put this on
iTunes what do I call iTunes well how do
I do this and someone said no no you
find yourself a hosting site it feeds it
everyone else you know once you ping it
in iTunes they'll start automatically
refreshing it at any time you put up an
episode so I got very into that I
started
kantha numbers and i started looking at
the cities that were the most popular
cities to listen to the show and and I
started seeing the the the trajectory of
the numbers and it was you know all that
stuff is like honestly very fascinating
to me when this my a person who ended up
being my business partner in Earwolf the
podcasting network that we created when
he came to me originally he was just
asking me about managing the show maybe
he was a business manager when we had
that meeting I was kind of not
interested because I had a manager and
on my way out the door he said you know
what would be really interesting but
it's probably too much work for you is
doing like a podcast network where we
get a bunch of shows and we all gang up
and we try to take on the industry
together and I said yes that's the idea
I like because I like doing really
complicated things that are ambitious
like I love doing the ambitious thing so
the the the problem at the time though
is to try to get a comedian to do a
podcast how do you get them to do it and
what we found was well we're a network
we'll buy all of the equipment we'll
rent the studio the comedian can just
show up record it leave and then we'll
upload it to the internet we'll track
all the numbers we'll sell all the merch
you know we had a garage that all the
merch was in that we would you know mail
it all out to people on the weekends if
you start to take care of that for
everyone then that can be a business and
so the comedians who we had shows with
most of them are just interested in the
side of the business where they can
increase their popularity through the
podcast which helps their touring which
helps their merch sales which makes them
money and I was always interested as
well in the other side of how do we help
people make money so to me that was
always made sense to me is to be the
person behind the scenes working with
people rather than just kind of being
the comedian who's like all right
someone record me and I'm gonna be
brilliant
it made more sense for me to be the guy
who was pushing other people up as well
[Music]